[Music]
there's a lot of thought about the
future of human occupied vehicles and
the fact of the matter is that it's
always more risky to put somebody at the
bottom of the ocean than it is to put a
robot I've been on a number of Dives in
Alin every single one I still get
butterflies in my stomach going down
descending through an hour of
Darkness there are very specific
conditions that the sub is allowed to
operate in very specific condition that
you're not allowed to operate in you
can't drive into a cave hot water is a
hazard to the vehicle underwater
volcanoes are obviously perfect example
of place where you wouldn't want to put
people you know it's like lava bombs
going off there's only 72 hours of
Reserve oxygen so that's where it is
coming upon the pilot to avoid being
entangled in anything that would keep
them stuck to the Sea Flor there are no
other vehicles to come out and Rescue a
submersible there's just nothing else
that would be in a close
proximity sub will never approach sunken
shipwrecks anymore there's too many
areas where the vehicle can get
entangled and that's good work for ROV
these
days this sort of question of comparing
rovs or remotely operated vehicles to HS
or human occupied Vehicles is sort of a
perennial one when I started Alvin was
really the only effective way to get to
the seaf Flor to do new science on the
sea Flor rovs were not a primary tool
for getting to the seafloor in the 25
years I've been at the institution rovs
have progressed to the point that now
they're a completely valid scientific
tool and and they're in use all over the
world if I use a remotely operated
vehicle I can take the robot down to the
seat Flor and leave it there for days on
end and slowly and meticulously work on
an area of the seafloor that's like a
few square meters what can be missing
though is the broader content text with
a remotely operated vehicle where you're
interacting with a screen the cameras
are seeing the same thing but you kind
of view that screen as the whole world
in submersible when you're down on the
sea4 you're looking out the viewport you
have the ability to take in a lot of
information and you're able to push
yourself a little bit because you can
kind of see where the light Fades from
the vehicle and say let's go a little
further let's move around the
corner I was on the first scientific
dive of the Albin after it was certified
and to actually climb into it and go to
the bottom of the ocean the views are
just spectacular it's unbelievable
conratulations
oh that work really neat yeah there
really is nothing like seeing the
environment firsthand but as we depend
more and more on Automation and try and
refine Technologies like 3D Vision and
the like we may find ourselves moving
away from Alvin and in 50 or 100 years
we may look back and think whoa boy we
really put people's lives at risk I
think the verdict still out
[Music]
though